OK, so before the president got coronavirus, which is sending everything now into some new and unforeseen reality, there were certain things about the election that had settled into predictable rhythms, right? The president will talk about rioters in the streets and law and order. Joe Biden will talk about Donald Trump's character and the way he's done his job.
好的，在总统感染新冠病毒——这让一切都陷入了某种未知的现实——之前，选举中有一些事情已经形成了可预测的节奏，对吧？总统会谈论街头的暴徒以及法律与秩序。乔·拜登会谈论唐纳德·特朗普的品格以及他履行职责的方式。
And when it came to the actual process of voting and the mail-in ballots that are going to be used by record numbers of people this year, the talking points lined up like this. The president said that mail-in ballots were going to be a disaster. Joe Biden said they were a perfectly good way to vote. The experts said the evidence backed up Biden.
而在实际的投票过程以及今年将有创纪录人数使用的邮寄选票方面，谈话要点是这样的：总统说邮寄选票将是一场灾难。乔·拜登说它们是完美的投票方式。专家们说证据支持拜登。
Then the president would again insist that they are a disaster. Biden would again say no. The experts would again back him up. The president again would call them a disaster, around and around and around in a circle that never ended, a very tedious circle.
然后总统会再次坚称它们是一场灾难。拜登会再次说不。专家们会再次支持他。总统再次称它们为灾难，就这样周而复始，陷入了一个永无止境、非常乏味的循环。
But, you know, we can remove ourselves from that circle, right? For a little perspective.
但是，你知道，我们可以跳出那个圈子，对吧？为了获得一点视角。
[DIAL TONE]
[拨号音]
Good evening, town of Nokomis.
晚上好，诺科米斯镇。
For a few weeks now, one of our producers, Ben Calhoun, has been calling around to the people who actually handle these ballots that everybody has been yelling about. These people touch them with their hands, and they stack them in stacks. Ben?
几周以来，我们的制片人之一本·卡尔霍恩一直在给那些真正处理这些每个人都在大声疾呼的选票的人打电话。这些人亲手接触这些选票，并将它们一叠一叠地码放好。本？
Yeah, so the person you're hearing, this is Wendy Smith. She's the person who's responsible for running the election and dealing with mail-in ballots and all that in a small town in my home state, which is Wisconsin. She's in Nokomis, which is way up north.
是的，你刚才听到的是温迪·史密斯。她负责在我家乡威斯康星州的一个小镇上组织选举、处理邮寄选票等事宜。她在诺科米斯，那是很靠北的地方。
And I called Wendy because I was wondering how this bizarre year was going for clerks like her. I had seen Wendy in a newspaper story. She had tattoos on both arms and this T-shirt that said, "Why should only one hour be happy?" And it said that she rode motorcycles.
我打电话给温迪，因为我想知道这个怪异的一年对像她这样的职员来说是怎么过的。我曾在报纸上看到过关于温迪的报道。她双臂上有纹身，穿着一件写着“为什么只有一小时是快乐的？”的T恤，上面还说她骑摩托车。
And I just kind of thought I wanted to talk to her. When I originally reached out to her, she was busy sending out absentee ballots to people who'd requested them.
我只是觉得我想和她聊聊。我最初联系她时，她正忙着给那些申请了缺席选票的人寄出选票。
You don't mind if I work and talk at the same time, do you?
你不介意我边工作边说话吧？
No, no, I actually imagine that you have a lot to do right now.
不，不，我其实能想象你现在有很多工作要做。
Yeah, I came in to 29 absentee ballots, and I've got a stack more that have to go.
是的，我收到了29张缺席选票，还有一堆需要处理。
Oh, wait, so how many total are you looking at compared to a normal year?
噢，等等，那么与正常年份相比，你总共处理了多少？
Oh my gosh. My last presidential, I had 100 absentee voters--
天哪。我上次总统大选时，有100名缺席选民——
Total.
总共。
--four years ago-- total. I've already almost tripled for this election what I did four years ago.
——四年前——总共。这次选举我已经处理了差不多是四年前三倍的数量。
Tripled. So that's like 300 voters out of maybe 1,000 that she's responsible for.
三倍。所以这大概是她负责的1000名选民中的300人左右。
Wow.
哇。
And she's getting more requests every week. I've talked to Wendy a couple times now, actually. And both times, she has worked the entire time that we've been talking. You can hear her keyboard and her printer going in the background the whole time.
而且她每周收到的申请越来越多。其实我已经和温迪聊过几次了。在这期间，我们谈话时她一直都在工作。你可以听到她键盘和打印机在后台工作的声音。
As I've been talking to you, I'm printing off all my absentee ballot requests because I have to have them open and done and in the mail today.
刚才和你谈话的时候，我正在打印我所有的缺席选票申请，因为我必须把它们全部处理完，并在今天寄出。
Wendy told me in all her years as clerk, this is definitely the most work she's ever had to do for elections. And one of the reasons for that is that the legislature and the governor keep fighting over how everything should run.
温迪告诉我，在她担任职员的所有年份里，这绝对是她为了选举必须做的最繁重的工作。原因之一是立法机构和州长一直在争论所有事情应该如何运作。
There are also lawsuits in Wisconsin, like there are all over the country, about what the rules for the election should be. And all the little changes that come out of that stuff can be a ton of extra work for Wendy.
和全国各地一样，威斯康星州也有关于选举规则的诉讼。由此产生的所有细小变化都可能给温迪带来大量额外的工作。
Like, in Wisconsin, at one point, they changed the rule about how many days somebody has to be a resident in order to vote. So Wendy started scrambling to fix all that. She's redoing all these envelopes. And then they just changed the rule back, meaning that all of that scrambling and work was for nothing.
比如，在威斯康星州，他们曾一度改变了投票所需居住天数的规定。所以温迪开始手忙脚乱地修正这一切。她重做了所有这些信封。然后他们又把规定改了回去，这意味着之前所有的忙乱和工作都白费了。
So then you went back to trusting your envelopes. Ugh. So all the envelopes that I pre-- you're laughing, but try being a one-man-show doing this.
所以你又回去相信你的那些信封了。呃。所以我所有的预先……你在笑，但试着成为一个独自处理这一切的人吧。
[LAUGHS] No, I'm just so sorry. I imagine you-- I just had an image of you buying Pepto Bismol at Costco by the case or something.
[笑] 不，我很抱歉。我能想象你……我脑海里浮现出你在Costco整箱购买胃药或者类似东西的画面。
Yeah.
是的。
And compared to a normal year, how many more times work do you feel like you're doing this year on elections?
与正常年份相比，你觉得今年在选举上投入的工作量多了多少倍？
It's a full-time job.
这是一份全职工作。
Is this your only job?
这是你唯一的工作吗？
No, this is my part-time job.
不，这是我的兼职工作。
[LAUGHS] What do you do when you're not doing this?
[笑] 你不做这个的时候做什么？
I work for an insurance company. I'm still working plus putting over time in there plus working here.
我在一家保险公司工作。我还在工作，加上在那边加班，再加上在这里工作。
Oh my gosh.
天哪。
Which is fine.
没关系的。
When do you sleep?
你什么时候睡觉？
Um--
嗯——
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
OK, so she's got the rule changes. She's got tons of extra ballots she's got to keep track of.
好的，所以她要处理规则变更，还要追踪大量额外的选票。
Mm-hmm, and the other big thing that's taking up a bunch more time is helping voters. Because people will just fill things out wrong, or they don't know where their ballot is. I talked to her the other day, and she was telling me about this couple.
嗯，另一件占用大量时间的事情是帮助选民。因为人们总是把事情填错，或者不知道他们的选票在哪里。前几天我和她聊天，她跟我说起一对夫妇。
I got to try to locate their number. They're snowbirds. Their ballot went down to Florida. They're not there yet. The ballot came back, and now I got to try to find a way to reach them.
我得设法找到他们的号码。他们是候鸟型居民。他们的选票被寄到了佛罗里达。他们还没到那儿。选票被退回来了，现在我得设法找到联系他们的方法。
Oh, wow.
噢，哇。
Right, so I get to dig through about 300 applications to try to find their-- see if they have a phone number.
对，所以我得翻遍大约300份申请，试图找到他们的……看看他们是否有电话号码。
So Wendy was trying to find them, which it seems like something she kind of does a lot. She digs up numbers for people. She finds people on Facebook.
所以温迪在努力找到他们，这似乎是她常做的事。她为人们找号码，她在Facebook上找人。
So now, I mean, I know where they live. I can probably drive over there when I'm done with work and say, hey, what do you want to do?
所以现在，我的意思是，我知道他们住哪儿。下班后我可能会开车过去，说，嘿，你们想怎么办？
The clerks that I've been talking to, they all kind of talk like this. They have this down-to-earth, sort of civic-mindedness.
我采访过的那些职员，说话风格都很像这样。他们有一种脚踏实地的、某种公民意识。
Yeah.
是的。
There's this other clerk, Marilynn Pedretti. She's in this town called Holland, which is slightly bigger than Nokomis. It's like 4,300 people. And Marilynn Pedretti spent five years in DC, where she worked for a congressman and then she worked in the Senate. But she got sick of Washington, and so she spent the last 20 years as the town clerk for Holland.
还有另一位职员，玛丽琳·佩德雷蒂。她在荷兰镇，比诺科米斯稍微大一点。大约有4300人。玛丽琳·佩德雷蒂在华盛顿特区工作了五年，她曾为一位国会议员工作，然后在参议院工作。但她厌倦了华盛顿，所以过去20年她一直担任荷兰镇的镇职员。
I want votes to count. I will not disenfranchise somebody and be lazy. I will do everything I can. I try to find their phone number first. If I can't find that, I try to email. If I don't have that, I'll send them a letter. So yeah, we're doing everything we can to make sure those votes count.
我希望选票能被计入。我不会剥夺某人的权利并变得懒惰。我会尽我所能。我先试着找他们的电话号码。如果找不到，我就试着发电子邮件。如果还是没有，我就给他们寄一封信。所以是的，我们正在竭尽全力确保这些选票被计入。
The one thing I find very frustrating is the conspiracy theories that are out there. And people believe them. I'm like, hello, I'm your town clerk. I am not going to throw your ballot away. And you can track it. There's no way I can throw your ballot away.
我感到非常沮丧的一点是外界存在的阴谋论。而且人们相信这些。我就像在说，你好，我是你的镇职员。我不会把你的选票扔掉。而且你可以追踪它。我根本没法扔掉你的选票。
So when you hear these stories about somebody picked some ballots out of a garbage and they open them up, it's like number one, whoever opened them up should be put in jail because you cannot open up the ballot. If it's sealed, you have to leave it sealed until election day.
所以当你听到有人从垃圾桶里挑出一些选票并打开它们的故事时，第一，任何打开它们的人都应该被关进监狱，因为你不能打开选票。如果它是密封的，你必须保持密封直到选举日。
And we have 1,800 municipalities in the state of Wisconsin. It's not centralized. It would take 1,800 clerks to do the wrong thing. Are there clerks out there that make mistakes? You bet. But when people come in with these conspiracies that the whole system is rigged, I'm like, no. No, it's not.
威斯康星州有1800个市镇。这不是中心化的。这需要1800名职员都做错事才行。有没有职员犯错误？当然有。但当人们带着这种“整个系统都被操纵了”的阴谋论进来时，我就说，不，不，根本不是这样。
All the clerks that I talked to-- and this is in Republican areas and Democratic areas. They all seemed like this was sort of driving them a little nuts, people getting the idea that what they do is very loosely goosey and that people are just going to cheat the system. To them, that's just outlandish because they say that there's too much security built into everything.
我采访的所有职员——包括共和党和民主党地区——都觉得这让他们有点抓狂，人们总觉得他们的工作非常随意，觉得人们会欺骗系统。对他们来说，这简直是荒谬的，因为他们说系统里嵌入了太多的安全性。
Security like what?
什么样的安全性？
Well, they keep track of every request for a ballot. Unless you can't leave the house, you have to submit your ID to get an absentee ballot. Clerks put tracking info on the ballot. And then they keep track of them when they're sent out and then coming back. And then when it comes back in, it has to have a voter signature and a witness signature for verification.
嗯，他们追踪每一份选票申请。除非你无法离开家，否则你必须提交身份证件才能获得缺席选票。职员会在选票上贴上追踪信息。然后他们会在选票寄出和收回时进行追踪。当它被收回时，必须有选民签名和证人签名以供核实。
At the end of the whole election, they also have to have report back to the state what ballots ended up where, like which ones went out and came back and which ones went out and never came back.
在整个选举结束时，他们还必须向州政府报告哪些选票流向了哪里，比如哪些发出了并收回了，哪些发出后就没回来。
Say somebody moves and they ask for a ballot in a new location, that's also something the state tracks. And I just want to say, Wisconsin is pretty typical for how all this stuff works.
假设某人搬家了，他们在新的地方申请选票，这也是州政府追踪的事项之一。我想说，威斯康星州在处理这些事情的流程上非常典型。
I feel like all these details exist in this universe that doesn't overlap in any way with the discussion that I see in the national media and the arguments that I heard during the presidential debate. It just seems kind of sad that that universe, the national politics universe, is lobbing grenades into these women's universe.
我觉得所有这些细节都存在于这个宇宙中，与我在全国性媒体讨论中看到的、以及在总统辩论中听到的争论毫无重叠。真令人难过，那个全国政治的宇宙竟然向这些女性的宇宙投掷手榴弹。
Yeah, I know. I mean, I've been at this for a couple weeks, and I haven't found one clerk that is worried about fraud. All of them are worried about the rule changes and the number of extra mail-in ballots. I mean, they think they can deal with that. It's just a lot more work.
是的，我知道。我的意思是，我做这个已经几周了，还没发现一个担心欺诈的职员。他们担心的都是规则变化和额外邮寄选票的数量。他们认为他们能应付这些。只是工作量大多了。
But they're running into these conspiracy theories a lot-- locally.
但他们在本地频繁遇到这些阴谋论。
Yeah, I know. Yeah, yeah, no, that's what I'm hearing. Marilynn, she's like Wendy. She's a clerk part-time. And she also gardens two acres, and she sells vegetables on the side of the highway.
是的，我知道。是的，是的，不，我听到的就是这样。玛丽琳，她就像温迪。她是兼职职员。她还种了两英亩的蔬菜，在公路边卖蔬菜。
I mean, I have a roadside stand, and I'm out there. And people know who I am. And they'll talk to me about election stuff, which is fun. But this woman who's out there buying my vegetables and knows that I'm the town clerk is telling me that all these dead people are voting.
我的意思是，我在路边有个摊位，我常在那里。人们知道我是谁。他们会跟我谈论选举的事情，这很有趣。但那个买我蔬菜并知道我是镇职员的女士，却在跟我说，所有死人都参加了投票。
And it's like, um, no. It's pretty much impossible in the state of Wisconsin for a dead person to vote. If they had died the day before election, maybe I'll not catch that, and maybe that ballot will go through. But that's one vote. It's not like the whole cemetery is voting.
我当时就像，嗯，不。在威斯康星州，死人投票几乎是不可能的。如果他们选举前一天去世，也许我没能及时发现，也许那张选票会通过。但这只是一票。并不是整个墓地的人都在投票。
And I just looked at her, said, ahem, you know I'm the clerk, right? Yeah, yeah. Do you think I would let dead people vote? Well, no, not you, but somewhere else. I said, can't happen in the state of Wisconsin. Well, um, it happens in other states. No, it doesn't. Stop listening to that stuff.
我看着她，说，咳咳，你知道我是职员，对吧？是的，是的。你认为我会让死人投票吗？好吧，不，不是你，是在别的地方。我说，在威斯康星州不可能发生。好吧，嗯，在别的州会发生。不，不会。别再听那些东西了。
And I do it cheerfully. I don't yell or anything. Just like, this is-- it's just wrong, and you've got to stop listening to that stuff.
我非常愉快地做这件事。我不大喊大叫。只是说，这是——这是不对的，你必须停止听那些东西。
Well, Ben Calhoun, thanks very much.
好吧，本·卡尔霍恩，非常感谢。
Oh, sure.
噢，不客气。
Are you going to stay in touch with these clerks as everything heats up in the next couple weeks?
随着未来几周形势愈演愈烈，你会与这些职员保持联系吗？
I mean, as long as they'll answer my calls.
只要他们愿意接听我的电话。
There are so many jobs like this around the country. Some of them are part-time, like with these two women. Some of them are full-time. Some are paid jobs, lots of volunteer or people get some tiny stipend.
全国各地有这么多这样的工作。其中一些是兼职的，就像这两位女性一样。一些是全职的。有些是有报酬的，很多是志愿的或者只领一点微薄的津贴。
These are people who are throwing themselves into the details of some tasks that just needs to get done for our country to function and doing it in the normal, decent, civic-minded way that you would imagine and that you would hope for.
这些人全身心地投入到一些为了国家正常运转而必须完成的琐事中，并以你所能想象和希望的那种正常、体面、有公民意识的方式来处理它们。
And it's corny to say it, but we are a country blessed with armies of people who are trying to contribute to their communities in all kinds of ways. And today's program is about a group of people like that, people who are, as best we can tell, trying to do a good job for all of us. They're trying to protect the public. But in this case, too often, they're failing.
说这话可能有点陈词滥调，但我们国家确实幸运地拥有成群结队的人，他们正以各种方式为社区做出贡献。今天的节目就是关于这样一群人，据我们所知，他们正在努力为我们所有人做好工作。他们试图保护公众。但在这种情况下，他们往往失败了。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Clinical Trial. So the people that most of today's program is about are doctors, doctors who've agreed to sit on panels to judge other doctors, to discipline them or revoke their licenses when they behave badly. Every state has these medical boards. They grant medical licenses, and they're the ones responsible for taking them away.
第一幕，临床试验。今天节目的大部分内容是关于医生的，那些同意组成小组来评判其他医生、在他们表现恶劣时进行纪律处分或吊销执照的医生。每个州都有这些医疗委员会。他们授予医疗执照，也是负责收回执照的人。
We heard about all this from a law professor at Vanderbilt, Rebecca Allensworth. In 2018, she started going to medical board hearings in Tennessee, where she lives. It was research for a book that she plans to write about licensing boards. And what she saw when she got there horrified her. Dana Chivvis is going to take it from here.
我们是从范德比尔特大学的法律教授丽贝卡·艾伦斯沃思那里听说这一切的。2018年，她开始参加她居住的田纳西州的医疗委员会听证会。这是她计划撰写的一本关于许可委员会的书的研究内容。当她到达那里时，她所看到的令她感到震惊。达纳·奇维斯将接手下面的内容。
When it comes to the Tennessee Board of Medical Examiners, Rebecca is like the one die-hard fan in the stands at a town softball game. She knows all the board members by name. She's interviewed most of them, attended all their meetings in person, or watched the livestream. She even went to their offsite retreat last year.
谈到田纳西州医疗审查委员会时，丽贝卡就像小镇垒球比赛看台上唯一的铁杆粉丝。她能叫出所有委员会成员的名字。她采访了他们中的大多数人，亲自参加了所有的会议，或者观看了直播。去年她甚至参加了他们的外部研讨会。
Before you went to any medical board meetings, how did you imagine they would be?
在你去参加任何医疗委员会会议之前，你是怎么想象它们的？
I thought they'd be pretty boring. But I think I also thought it was going to be in some sort of grand state government building. I think I had our state capital in mind or something. But it's just like an office park.
我以为它们会很无聊。但我认为我也以为它会在某种宏伟的州政府大楼里举行。我想我当时想的是州议会大厦什么的。但它就像一个办公园区。
So yeah, so describe what it actually looked like.
所以，描述一下它实际上看起来是什么样的。
It's like a three or four-story square office building probably built in the '70s or '80s. This is Nashville, so there's copious parking and--
就像一栋可能建于70年代或80年代的三四层高的方形办公楼。这是纳什维尔，所以停车位很充足，还有——
It sounds like Dunder Mifflin to me.
听起来像《办公室》里的邓德·米夫林公司。
Oh my god, it looked just like Dunder Mifflin. It looked just like Dunder Mifflin.
天哪，它看起来简直就像邓德·米夫林。看起来一模一样。
The first meeting she went to, an OB-GYN appeared before the board to request a new medical license. The board had taken his old license away six months before when they learned that he'd had sex with 11 of his patients. He'd done drugs with at least one of them, too. He'd also prescribe them and other people who were not his patients controlled substances, like codeine and Xanax.
她参加的第一次会议上，一位妇产科医生出现在委员会面前，请求获得新的医疗执照。六个月前，当委员会得知他曾与11名患者发生性关系时，撤销了他的旧执照。他也至少与其中一名患者一起吸过毒。他还向她们以及其他非他患者的人开具受控物质，如可待因和赞安诺。
So this doctor was there to ask the medical board for a new license. All that stuff, the sex, the drugs, had happened years before. He'd been to rehab, was sober now, saw the error in his old ways. And the board gave him a new license with some conditions attached, but he could practice medicine again. Rebecca couldn't believe it.
所以这位医生到那里是请求医疗委员会给他一个新的执照。所有这些事，性、毒品，都发生在几年前。他已经去过康复中心，现在清醒了，看到了他旧日的错误。委员会给了他一个新的执照，并附加了一些条件，但他可以再次从医。丽贝卡简直不敢相信。
There just has to be some sins that are unforgivable in the eyes of the board. The board is a regulatory body. They're not your priest. They're not deciding whether or not you're really sorry. They're deciding whether or not you're a safe provider.
在委员会眼中，一定有一些罪行是不可饶恕的。委员会是一个监管机构。他们不是你的牧师。他们不是在决定你是否真的感到抱歉。他们是在决定你是否是一个安全的医务提供者。
Officially, the board's mission is to protect the health, safety, and welfare of people in the state of Tennessee. Board members and staff repeat that mission all the time, like a mantra.
正式地，委员会的使命是保护田纳西州人民的健康、安全和福祉。委员会成员和工作人员一直重复这一使命，就像咒语一样。
But since Rebecca has been following the board, she's seen a bunch of cases like that OB-GYN, where doctors have done something really bad, seemingly irredeemable, and somehow, they've managed to keep their medical licenses. They're out there, working as doctors in Tennessee right now.
但自从丽贝卡开始关注委员会以来，她看到了很多像那位妇产科医生一样的案例，医生们做了一些非常糟糕、看似不可救药的事情，但不知何故，他们设法保住了医疗执照。他们现在就在田纳西州作为医生工作。
So this became the question of her research. What was going wrong in the system? Why were these doctors allowed to keep working? One case in particular became the focus of her attention because it seemed like a perfect storm of regulatory failure.
于是这成了她研究的问题。系统中出了什么问题？为什么这些医生被允许继续工作？其中一个案例特别引起了她的注意，因为它看起来像是监管失败的完美风暴。
And that's what I want to tell you about today. It's about a doctor named Michael LaPaglia. I'll start the story back in 2013. LaPaglia was working as an ER doctor at the time. And late one night, police got a call about a domestic disturbance at his house.
这就是我今天要告诉你的。关于一位名叫迈克尔·拉帕利亚的医生。我把故事带回到2013年。拉帕利亚当时是一名急诊室医生。一天深夜，警察接到一个关于他家里家庭纠纷的电话。
When the police arrived, they smelled weed and searched the house. They found-- actually, let me just read from the police officer's affidavit.
警察到达时，闻到了大麻的味道并搜查了房子。他们发现了——事实上，让我读一下警察的宣誓书。
Quote, "A search of the residence pursuant to the search warrant revealed 45 quart-sized Mason jars which contained marijuana, 127 glass pipes used to smoke marijuana, Glock 19 9 millimeter, grow light with ballast, timer, digital scale, and ledger detailing names/amounts. Also discovered were approximately 52 diazepam, 22 amphetamine, and 24 oxycodone pills."
引用：“根据搜查令对住宅进行的搜查发现了45个装有大麻的夸脱大小的梅森罐，127个用于吸食大麻的玻璃烟斗，一把格洛克19 9毫米手枪，带有镇流器的生长灯，定时器，数字秤，以及详细记录了姓名/金额的分类账。此外还发现了大约52片地西泮，22片安非他命和24片羟考酮药丸。”
In addition, the police found on a shelf in LaPaglia's office vials of fentanyl, morphine, and propofol, which is used for general anesthesia. LaPaglia's girlfriend told police that he had threatened to use that stuff to kill her.
此外，警察在拉帕利亚办公室的架子上发现了芬太尼、吗啡和异丙酚，后者用于全身麻醉。拉帕利亚的女友告诉警察，他曾威胁要用这些东西杀死她。
In the petition she filed for a restraining order the next day, she said, quote, "Michael told me that if I ever contacted the police for help or reported his drug use, Michael would use his powers as a physician to have me committed to psychiatric facility. Michael stated he would make sure my body wouldn't be found. Michael stated that he would take my life away. I'm in fear for my life and my son's life."
在第二天她提交的限制令申请中，她说，引用：“迈克尔告诉我，如果我联系警察寻求帮助或报告他的药物滥用情况，迈克尔会利用他作为医生的权力将我关进精神病院。迈克尔说他会确保我的尸体找不到。迈克尔说他会夺走我的生命。我为自己和儿子的生命感到恐惧。”
LaPaglia told police his girlfriend was delusional. He was arrested and charged with two drug felonies, intent to distribute a controlled substance, and intent to distribute marijuana. He pled no contest and went to inpatient rehab. He was addicted to Valium at the time.
拉帕利亚告诉警察他的女友有妄想症。他被逮捕并被指控犯有两项毒品重罪，意图分发受控物质和意图分发大麻。他没有抗辩，并进入了住院康复中心。他当时对安定药成瘾。
He lost his job at the hospital. The medical board put him on probation. And he surrendered his DEA registration number, which is the thing you have to have to prescribe controlled substances. That's a big deal. It's very hard to get a job once you've lost your DEA number.
他失去了在医院的工作。医疗委员会让他处于缓刑期。他上交了他的DEA注册号码，这是开具受控物质所必须的东西。这是一件大事。一旦失去DEA号码，很难找到工作。
No one wants to touch him. No employer is going to take him-- very few employers anyway-- with a record like that. Private insurance, forget it. Hospital, forget it. A few years later, he files for bankruptcy because there's no way to earn money back at the same clip as you are as an ER physician.
没人想碰他。没有雇主会录用他——反正雇主很少——带着那样的记录。私人保险，想都别想。医院，想都别想。几年后，他申请了破产，因为不可能再像作为急诊医生那样赚回同样多的钱。
But he got a job at an addiction clinic a friend of his owned. It was called EHC, Express Health Care. LaPaglia would see patients like a regular doctor, work up a treatment plan and everything, and then another doctor would write their prescriptions.
但他从他朋友拥有的一个成瘾诊所得到了一份工作。它叫EHC，快递健康护理。拉帕利亚会像普通医生一样看病，制定治疗计划等等，然后另一位医生会开出处方。
Dr. LaPaglia helped a friend of his, Dr. Charles Brooks, get a job at Express Health Care, too. Dr. Brooks was also on probation with the medical board. He'd had sex with a patient-- he says they were having an affair-- and at least once given her a controlled substance-- he says to calm her nerves because they were having an affair.
拉帕利亚医生也帮助他的朋友查尔斯·布鲁克斯医生在快递健康护理中心找到了一份工作。布鲁克斯医生也处于医疗委员会的缓刑期。他曾与一名患者发生过性关系——他说他们是在搞外遇——并且至少有一次给了她一种受控物质——他说是因为他们有外遇，为了让她镇定下来。
But unlike Dr. LaPaglia, he did not lose his DEA number. He could still prescribe. Dr. LaPaglia left EHC. And in early 2018, he and Dr. Brooks started up a little side business.
但与拉帕利亚医生不同的是，他没有失去DEA号码。他仍然可以开处方。拉帕利亚医生离开了EHC。2018年初，他和布鲁克斯医生开始了一个小副业。
So he and Dr. Brooks kind of hatched this plan. LaPaglia and Brooks realized, OK, well, here's what we're going to do. We're going to start a clinic called L&B Healthcare, LaPaglia and Brooks. But LaPaglia doesn't have a DEA number, so we'll use Brooks's.
所以他和布鲁克斯制定了这个计划。拉帕利亚和布鲁克斯意识到，好吧，我们就这么干。我们将成立一个叫L&B医疗的诊所，拉帕利亚和布鲁克斯。但拉帕利亚没有DEA号码，所以我们用布鲁克斯的。
LaPaglia is going to do the work. He was going to write the prescriptions. It's his phone number on the prescription pad that they make out. But it's Brooks's DEA number, and it's Brooks's signature. Sometimes they were presigned. Sometimes LaPaglia forged the signature. Oh, and they sell them for $300 cash out of LaPaglia's home, at least once in a McDonald's parking lot.
拉帕利亚将去做这份工作。他要写处方。处方笺上的电话号码是他们的。但那是布鲁克斯的DEA号码，也是布鲁克斯的签名。有时它们是预先签名的。有时拉帕利亚伪造签名。哦，他们至少有一次在麦当劳的停车场，以300美元现金的价格售卖这些处方。
L&B Healthcare didn't have an actual brick and mortar office. LaPaglia would see people wherever it was convenient, write prescriptions for controlled substances, like Klonopin, Valium, and Suboxone. When the facts came out about their operation, it looked like they were selling prescriptions for cash, like drug dealers with stethoscopes.
L&B医疗并没有实际的实体办公室。拉帕利亚会在任何方便的地方看病人，为受控物质开具处方，如氯硝西泮、安定和舒必松。当关于他们的行动的事实浮出水面时，看起来他们就是在卖处方换钱，就像带着听诊器的毒贩。
LaPaglia and Brooks say that's not the case at all, that they were legitimately treating people with addiction problems by prescribing them controlled substances. It's something called medication-assisted treatment, like the way methadone is used to treat heroin addictions. So that's what they said they were doing.
拉帕利亚和布鲁克斯说根本不是那么回事，他们是在通过开具受控物质来合法地治疗有成瘾问题的患者。这叫做药物辅助治疗，就像美沙酮被用来治疗海洛因成瘾一样。所以这就是他们所说的正在做的事情。
Regardless, it was still illegal. A few months into the venture, the Feds busted them, charged them with drug trafficking, for writing prescriptions for controlled substances without the authority to do so, and fraud for using Brooks's DEA number in the scam. Brooks pled not guilty, but Dr. LaPaglia signed a plea deal with federal prosecutors. He's still waiting to be sentenced, but he could be facing prison time.
无论如何，这仍然是非法的。在冒险开始几个月后，联邦调查局抓获了他们，指控他们进行毒品交易，因为他们在没有授权的情况下开具受控物质处方，并欺诈地使用了布鲁克斯的DEA号码。布鲁克斯拒不认罪，但拉帕利亚医生与联邦检察官签署了认罪协议。他还在等待判决，但他可能面临监禁。
So that's the federal criminal court. LaPaglia still had to face the Tennessee Medical Board. And when they found out about L&B Healthcare, they summarily suspended the doctors' medical licenses until they could hold disciplinary hearings for them. The case unfolded over three hearings from March to July 2019.
这就是联邦刑事法庭的情况。拉帕利亚仍然必须面对田纳西州医疗委员会。当他们发现L&B医疗的事情时，他们立刻暂停了这两位医生的医疗执照，直到他们可以为他们举行纪律听证会。案件在2019年3月至7月的三个听证会上展开。
The first one in March was the disciplinary hearing for LaPaglia's partner, Dr. Brooks. Rebecca was there. She'd been going to medical board meetings for a year at that point.
3月的第一次听证会是拉帕利亚的合伙人布鲁克斯医生的纪律听证会。丽贝卡就在现场。在那之前，她已经参加了一年的医疗委员会会议。
And I see this guy who is doing something that actually even I think the physicians on the board find really offensive, which is giving up control of your pad. And to hand it over to somebody else is really seen as pretty unethical. Most doctors don't view their pad as a moneymaker.
我看到这个人做的事情甚至我认为委员会里的内科医生也觉得非常冒犯，那就是放弃对自己处方权的控制。把它交给别人确实被认为是非常不道德的。大多数医生并不把他们的处方本视为赚钱工具。
These medical board disciplinary hearings are technically administrative courts. They run kind of like the criminal and civil court systems. But the question they're addressing is more pointed. It's whether a doctor should be allowed to continue to practice medicine. Dr. LaPaglia agreed to testify against Dr. Brooks in front of the medical board.
这些医疗委员会纪律听证会技术上是行政法庭。它们的运作方式有点像刑事和民事法庭系统。但他们解决的问题更尖锐。就是是否应该允许医生继续行医。拉帕利亚医生同意在医疗委员会面前作证反对布鲁克斯医生。
The signature on that prescription says Charles Brooks, correct?
那张处方上的签名是查尔斯·布鲁克斯，对吗？
Correct.
对。
Is that your signature there?
那是你的签名吗？
That's my writing, yes.
那是我的笔迹，是的。
Just to set the stage, the guy asking the questions is Andrew Coffman. He's the prosecuting attorney. He works for the Tennessee Department of Health. Dr. LaPaglia is the one answering his questions.
为了交代背景，提问的人是安德鲁·考夫曼。他是检察官。他在田纳西州卫生部工作。拉帕利亚医生是回答他问题的人。
While you are partners with Dr. Brooks, to your knowledge, was he aware that you were signing his name to blank prescriptions?
在你与布鲁克斯医生合伙期间，据你所知，他是否知道你在空白处方上签了他的名字？
Yes.
是的。
What makes you think that he was aware?
是什么让你觉得他知道？
Because sometimes I would run out of presigned prescriptions and had to do what I had to do to take care of the patient. And we've discussed it.
因为有时我的预签名处方用完了，必须做我必须做的事情来照顾病人。我们讨论过。
When you went to work for-- with Dr. Brooks, did you believe that what you were doing was against the law?
当你去与布鲁克斯医生一起工作时，你是否相信你所做的事情是违法的？
No.
没有。
Dr. LaPaglia was like, yeah, I think we probably cut some corners. I think, you know, mistakes were made.
拉帕利亚医生就像是说，是的，我想我们可能走了一些捷径。我想，你知道，犯了一些错误。
No, we discussed it, and we knew that what we were doing wasn't ideal because we had very little resources to get started. But we never imagined that we were breaking the law.
不，我们讨论过，我们知道我们做的事情并不理想，因为我们开始时几乎没有资源。但我们从未想过我们触犯了法律。
His general attitude was like, error in judgment, not a big deal.
他总体的态度就像是，判断错误，没什么大不了。
But has your opinion changed about whether you were breaking the law?
但你对于自己是否触犯了法律的看法改变了吗？
Yes.
改变了。
Why?
为什么？
Because federal prosecutors have convinced me otherwise.
因为联邦检察官让我相信了这一点。
I spoke with Dr. LaPaglia. He didn't want me to record our conversation. And we didn't talk for long before he got off the phone. But he reiterated to me that he and Dr. Brooks didn't think they were doing anything wrong. When they worked in addiction clinics, the doctors there would hand prescriptions to receptionists. And the receptionist would call them into a pharmacy. It happened all the time.
我和拉帕利亚医生谈过。他不想让我录下我们的对话。我们在挂电话之前也没聊太久。但他向我重申，他和布鲁克斯医生并不认为他们做了什么错事。当他们在成瘾诊所工作时，那里的医生会把处方交给前台接待员。然后接待员会打电话给药房。这经常发生。
He told me, quote, "We did not see any difference between him giving me verbal authorization to call them in and verbal authorization to write a prescription. I still don't see a difference. And if someone had a problem with that, the federal government had a problem with that, they could have just told us to stop. They didn't have to indict us and charge us with two felonies."
他告诉我，引用：“我们没觉得他给我口头授权打电话和口头授权写处方有什么区别。我至今没看出区别。如果有人对此有意见，联邦政府有意见，他们本可以告诉我们停止。他们不必起诉我们并指控我们犯有两项重罪。”
I reached out to Dr. LaPaglia several times after that initial call, but he declined my request to talk further. There were three board members hearing Dr. Brooks's case that day. And they were not swayed by this defense that they didn't know they were doing anything wrong, that they were just trying to help their drug-sick patients.
在那次初步通话后，我多次联系拉帕利亚医生，但他拒绝了我进一步交谈的请求。那天有三名委员会成员听取了布鲁克斯医生的案件。他们并没有被这种“他们不知道自己在做错事，他们只是想帮助成瘾的病人”的辩解所动摇。
In fact, the board members suspected that L&B Healthcare was not a legitimate business at all. Here's Dr. Charles Handorf, one of the board members, questioning Dr. LaPaglia.
事实上，委员会成员怀疑L&B医疗根本不是一个合法的业务。这是委员会成员查尔斯·汉多夫医生在质询拉帕利亚医生。
Did the clinic ever apply for or receive a business license?
诊所有没有申请或收到营业执照？
No.
没有。
Did the clinic ever apply for or register articles of incorporation with the Secretary of State--
诊所有没有向州务卿申请或注册公司章程——
No.
没有。
--of Tennessee? Has the clinic ever filed tax returns?
——田纳西州的？诊所有没有提交过纳税申报表？
Um, not to date, no.
嗯，到目前为止还没有。
OK, so sitting here, it sounds like this isn't a business at all.
好吧，坐在这里，听起来这根本不是什么生意。
So that was Dr. LaPaglia testifying at Dr. Brooks's disciplinary hearing in front of the medical board. Once Brooks's case was adjudicated, it was LaPaglia's turn for discipline. He and his attorney had worked out a deal with Andrew Coffman, the Department of Health attorney.
所以那是拉帕利亚医生在医疗委员会面前的布鲁克斯医生纪律听证会上的证词。布鲁克斯案审判后，轮到拉帕利亚接受纪律处分了。他和他的律师已经与卫生部律师安德鲁·考夫曼达成了一项协议。
It's called the consent order. It's basically the board's version of a plea deal. So at the next board meeting in May, Coffman presented this deal to the board members. The board had to decide whether to accept it.
它叫同意令。它基本上是委员会版本的认罪协议。所以在5月的下一次委员会会议上，考夫曼向委员会成员提出了这个协议。委员会必须决定是否接受它。
Good morning, Andrew Coffman with the Office of General Counsel.
早上好，我是法律顾问办公室的安德鲁·考夫曼。
And here's what the deal was. Basically, LaPaglia could go back to practicing medicine in another month. But he'd be on probation for five years, and he'd have to be monitored by a physicians' addiction group. And he'd be banned from prescribing controlled substances for two years.
交易是这样的。基本上，拉帕利亚可以在一个月后重返医疗岗位。但他将处于五年缓刑期，并且必须受到医生成瘾小组的监督。并且他将被禁止开具受控物质两年。
It's similar to what Dr. Brooks got in March, but slightly less because LaPaglia had admitted guilt and had testified against Brooks. It's what they call a downward departure in the criminal system. Cooperating witnesses often get lighter sentences. It's supposed to give people an incentive to tell the truth.
这与布鲁克斯医生3月获得的结果类似，但略少，因为拉帕利亚承认了罪行并作证反对了布鲁克斯。这就是他们在刑事系统中所谓的向下偏离。配合调查的证人通常会获得较轻的判决。这旨在给人一个说实话的动力。
But the board was not having it with this deal. They looked at LaPaglia and saw a guy whose medical license was already on probation when he used another doctor's prescription pad to write controlled substance prescriptions. Here's Dr. John Hale, one of the board members.
但委员会并不接受这个协议。他们看着拉帕利亚，看到了一个在他已经处于缓刑期的医疗执照下，使用另一位医生的处方本开具受控物质处方的人。这是委员会成员约翰·黑尔医生。
This seems rather light. I mean, we just had a physician whose prescriptions were stolen, and his fines were significantly more than that. I can't, in good conscience, approve of this. I'm sorry.
这看起来相当轻。我的意思是，我们刚刚有一个医生的处方被窃，他的罚款比这重得多。凭良心说，我不能批准这个。很抱歉。
The board has 12 members appointed by the governor. And three of them are not doctors. They're called consumer members-- in this case, a real estate agent, an academic advisor, and a political fundraiser. They were even more pissed than the doctors on the board.
委员会由州长任命的12名成员组成。其中三人不是医生。他们被称为消费者成员——在这个案例中，是一名房地产经纪人、一名学术顾问和一名政治筹款人。他们比委员会里的医生还要愤怒。
This man doesn't need to be on the streets or in his office, writing prescriptions in the state of Tennessee, as far as I'm concerned. And we're charged with the responsibility of protecting the citizens of Tennessee, so that's my concern. So how do we get to that point?
据我所知，这个人不应该出现在街头或他的办公室里，在田纳西州开处方。我们肩负着保护田纳西州公民的责任，所以这是我的担忧。那么我们如何走到那一步呢？
Well, the only thing you can do today is reject this order.
好吧，你今天唯一能做的就是拒绝这个命令。
Thank you, counselor. That's all the--
谢谢，顾问。这就是所有——
Ms. Cole, I would really appreciate your insight, too, as a consumer member.
科尔女士，作为一名消费者成员，我也非常感谢您的见解。
I share their feelings completely. I live in Knoxville. I know this McDonald's. To think that he could be back there ever is scary to me as a consumer member. And as I have young daughters, and this man is not safe to be out in the public, I don't think.
我完全赞同他们的感受。我住在诺克斯维尔。我知道这个麦当劳。想到他能回到那里，作为一名消费者成员，我感到害怕。作为一个有年幼女儿的人，我认为这个人不安全，不应该出现在公共场合。
Just a tour guide's representation here, this McDonald's is two blocks away from one of the major high schools in Knoxville. So again, I agree with her. This man does not need to be on the streets with this type of ability.
作为一个导游的陈述，这个麦当劳距离诺克斯维尔的主要高中之一只有两个街区。所以再次重申，我同意她的看法。这个人不需要带着这种能力出现在街上。
All in favor of denying the motion for this order on LaPaglia, say aye.
所有赞成否决拉帕利亚命令动议的人，请说“同意”。
Aye.
同意。
The board rejected the plea deal. It was unanimous. So now Dr. LaPaglia's case will go to trial, or the medical board version of a trial, a contested case hearing, where he has the possibility of getting a much heavier discipline. They could suspend his license for even longer, for instance, or even revoke it altogether.
委员会否决了认罪协议。是一致否决。所以现在拉帕利亚医生的案件将进入审判，或者说医疗委员会版本的审判，即有争议的案件听证会，在那里他有可能获得更重的纪律处分。例如，他们可以让他停职更长时间，甚至完全吊销他的执照。
I had been following this case. And so, yeah, I wanted a full hearing. I wanted the opportunity to see Dr. LaPaglia testify and maybe try to talk to him. And I figured everything was lining up for them to finally throw the book at somebody.
我一直在关注这个案子。所以，是的，我想要一个完整的听证会。我想要机会看到拉帕利亚医生作证，也许试着和他谈谈。我觉得一切都已准备就绪，他们终于可以严惩某人了。
Rebecca had been to several of these disciplinary hearings by then. She'd seen so many doctors get away with what she considered to be light punishments. But it seemed like the board was finally going to put its foot down with LaPaglia.
到那时，丽贝卡已经参加了几个这样的纪律听证会。她看到太多的医生因为她认为轻微的惩罚而逍遥法外。但看起来委员会终于要对拉帕利亚采取强硬态度了。
Dana Chivvis. Coming up, what goes wrong when the board gets a chance to finally put its foot down. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
达纳·奇维斯。接下来，当委员会终于有机会严惩某人时，出了什么问题。一会儿从芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Trust Me, I'm a Doctor." We have stories about people trying to do civic-minded things for their own communities and, in the case of medical boards, sometimes failing to accomplish that job the way that lots of us would want them to.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“相信我，我是医生”。我们有一些故事是关于人们试图为他们自己的社区做一些有公民意识的事情，而在医疗委员会的情况下，有时却未能以我们许多人希望的方式完成这项工作。
Right now, we are in the middle of Dana Chivvis's story, and we pick up where we left off. The Medical Board in Tennessee has rejected Dr. LaPaglia's plea deal. And two months after that, at their next meeting, the board holds a hearing for his case. Here's Dana.
现在，我们正处于达纳·奇维斯故事的中间，我们从中断的地方继续。田纳西州医疗委员会拒绝了拉帕利亚医生的认罪协议。两个月后，在下一次会议上，委员会为他的案件举行了听证会。这是达纳。
How these hearings work, they're basically mini trials. Each case gets assigned to a panel of three board members. LaPaglia's panel was made up of two doctors and a consumer member. They sit at the front of the room, facing everyone else.
这些听证会是如何运作的，它们基本上是小型审判。每个案件都被分配给一个由三名委员会成员组成的小组。拉帕利亚的小组由两名医生和一名消费者成员组成。他们坐在房间的前面，面对其他人。
And they're going to decide if the prosecutor has proven his case, and if so, how to discipline Dr. LaPaglia. There's also an administrative law judge, who acts as a referee, more than anything else.
他们将决定检察官是否证明了他的案件，如果是，如何惩罚拉帕利亚医生。还有一名行政法法官，他扮演的角色更像是一名裁判。
Today, the board will be considering the case of the Tennessee Department of Health versus Michael LaPaglia.
今天，委员会将审议田纳西州卫生部诉迈克尔·拉帕利亚案。
They hold Dr. LaPaglia's hearing in the Iris Room, a name which defies the interior decorator's vision-- beige carpet, beige walls, fluorescent lights. Dr. LaPaglia is sitting at a table with his attorney, facing the panel. The prosecutor, Andrew Coffman, he's sitting at a table to the right. And Rebecca's there, too, in the front row.
他们在艾里斯房间举行了拉帕利亚医生的听证会，这个名字与室内设计师的构思背道而驰——米色地毯、米色墙壁、荧光灯。拉帕利亚医生和他的律师坐在桌子旁，面对着委员会。检察官安德鲁·考夫曼坐在右边的桌子旁。丽贝卡也在第一排。
It was really weird. It was weird from the first moment when they did opening statements.
这真的很奇怪。从他们做开场白的第一刻起就很奇怪。
Good morning. I'm Andrew Coffman. You heard me introduce myself earlier.
早上好。我是安德鲁·考夫曼。你们刚才听到我做了自我介绍。
The prosecutor went first, Mr. Coffman, and he said--
检察官先发言，考夫曼先生说——
We're going to hear a lot of facts today, good, bad, and ugly.
我们今天会听到很多事实，好的、坏的、丑陋的。
--this is a rare case where we basically agree with defense counsel on everything.
——这是一个罕见的案例，我们基本上在所有事情上都同意辩护律师的观点。
And in an unusual twist, there's not much dispute between the parties about what those facts are, whether they're good, bad, or ugly.
而且在一个不寻常的转折中，双方对于这些事实——无论是好的、坏的还是丑陋的——并没有太大的争议。
And it was just kind of a half-hearted prosecution. I mean, OK, it's an administrative hearing. It's a little more casual than a criminal trial or something. But it's meant to be adversarial.
这只是一种半心半意的起诉。我的意思是，好吧，这是一个行政听证会。它比刑事审判什么的更随意一些。但它本应是对抗性的。
Now I think that the evidence is going to show that Dr. LaPaglia believed that he was providing good treatment to people that actually had a need for that treatment.
现在我认为证据将表明，拉帕利亚医生相信他是在为那些真正需要这种治疗的人提供良好的治疗。
Coffman is there to prosecute LaPaglia, but it seems like he's going pretty easy on him, like that 2013 drug bust, the one where the cops found Valium, Oxycodone, amphetamines, marijuana, a gun, a scale, a ledger, paralytic agents, and other sedatives. Coffman doesn't say the charge was possession with intent to deliver. He just says LaPaglia pled to some charges--
考夫曼在那里起诉拉帕利亚，但看起来他对他很宽容，比如2013年的那次毒品搜查，警察发现了安定、羟考酮、安非他命、大麻、一把枪、一个秤、一本分类账、麻痹剂和其他镇静剂。考夫曼没有说指控是持有并意图分发。他只是说拉帕利亚对一些指控进行了认罪——
That related to his own personal use of controlled substances, outside the bounds of the law. And the very next month--
这与他个人在法律范围之外使用受控物质有关。就在下一个月——
If I were prosecuting, I would probably use some stronger language.
如果我是检察官，我可能会使用一些更强硬的语言。
LaPaglia is coming across as a guy who once struggled with a substance use disorder, but got help, sobered up, and then, in the course of trying to help other people who suffer from drug addictions, unwittingly bumbled his way into this next bit of trouble with Dr. Brooks. Here's how LaPaglia's defense attorney also described him in his opening statement.
拉帕利亚给人的印象是一个曾经与物质使用障碍作斗争，但得到了帮助、变得清醒，然后在试图帮助其他遭受毒瘾折磨的人的过程中，无意中搞砸了与布鲁克斯医生的下一件麻烦事。这是拉帕利亚的辩护律师在开场白中对他描述的方式。
He may be dumb, but he's a good doctor. He's responsible. He's done a lot to help the community.
他可能很笨，但他是一位好医生。他负责任。他为社区做了很多贡献。
It's like everyone in this trial was on Dr. LaPaglia's side.
就像这场审判中的每个人都站在拉帕利亚医生一边。
I asked Andrew Coffman why he handled the case the way he did. He said, basically, this case wasn't contentious by its very nature. His job was to prove that Dr. LaPaglia Paglia had written prescriptions for controlled substances using another doctor's prescription pad. His star witness? Dr. LaPaglia, who had admitted repeatedly that yes, he had used Dr. Brooks's pad to write prescriptions for controlled substances.
我问安德鲁·考夫曼为什么要这样处理这个案子。他说，基本上，这个案子本质上就没有争议。他的工作是证明拉帕利亚医生使用另一位医生的处方本开具了受控物质处方。他的明星证人？拉帕利亚医生本人，他反复承认是的，他用了布鲁克斯医生的本子开具受控物质处方。
But also, there's another reason why the prosecution was maybe a bit anemic in this case. The Department of Health attorneys, Coffman and his colleagues, were feeling frustrated. When this whole thing started back in March at Dr. Brooks's hearing-- Dr. Brooks, LaPaglia's coconspirator-- Coffman had asked the board to revoke Dr. Brooks's license. But the board rejected that and said it was too harsh.
但同时，起诉书在这个案子中显得有点贫血还有另一个原因。卫生部的律师们，考夫曼和他的同事们，感到很沮丧。当这一切在3月份布鲁克斯医生的听证会上开始时——布鲁克斯是拉帕利亚的同谋——考夫曼曾要求委员会吊销布鲁克斯医生的执照。但委员会拒绝了，说太严厉了。
So the prosecutors went easier on LaPaglia in his plea deal. And then the board rejected that, said it went too easy on him. There was no consistency to their logic. Coffman's boss said later at a board retreat where they discussed this case that they felt a little bit knocked down by the whole thing.
所以检察官在拉帕利亚的认罪协议中更加宽容。然后委员会拒绝了，说对他太容易了。他们的逻辑没有任何一致性。考夫曼的老板后来在一次委员会研讨会上讨论这个案子时说，他们觉得被整个事情搞得有点消沉。
So at LaPaglia's hearing, Coffman just presented the straight facts of the case and told the panel what their options were for disciplining him, didn't suggest a punishment. They didn't know what the hell the board wanted, so they didn't try to guess. And this brings us to the single biggest problem Rebecca sees in the system-- the doctors who sit on these medical boards.
所以在拉帕利亚的听证会上，考夫曼只是陈述了案件的直白事实，并告诉委员会成员他们有什么纪律处分选择，没有建议惩罚。他们不知道委员会到底想要什么，所以他们没有试图猜测。这带来了丽贝卡在系统中看到的单一最大问题——坐在这些医疗委员会里的医生们。
It's a distinguished position to be on the Tennessee Board of Medical Examiners. They have to be appointed by the governor. There is a full-time staff that supports the board-- attorneys, administrators, medical consultants. And they sit in judgment of doctors. But as far as judges go, they're amateurs. Most of them are doctors. They have lots of training in medicine and very little training in administrative law.
进入田纳西州医疗审查委员会是一个杰出的职位。他们必须由州长任命。有一个支持委员会的全职工作人员——律师、行政人员、医疗顾问。他们对医生进行评判。但就法官而言，他们是业余爱好者。他们中的大多数是医生。他们在医学方面有大量的培训，在行政法方面的培训却很少。
The deciders in Dr. LaPaglia's case, the three board members on this panel, were Julianne Cole-- she's a consumer member-- Dr. Phyllis Miller, an OB-GYN, and Dr. Stephen Loyd. Dr. Loyd was the newest member of the board. He'd never done any of this before. In fact, this was his second day on the job.
拉帕利亚医生案件的决策者，这个小组的三名委员会成员，是朱莉安娜·科尔——她是消费者成员——菲利斯·米勒医生（妇产科医生）和斯蒂芬·劳埃德医生。劳埃德医生是委员会的新成员。他从来没有做过任何这样的事情。事实上，这是他上任的第二天。
I hadn't even had orientation. I mean, I walked in there-- and never been to a board meeting. I read all the rulings--
我甚至还没参加迎新会。我的意思是，我走进去——从来没参加过委员会会议。我读了所有的裁决——
When they were like, we're going to split off into panels for the contested case hearings now, did you have any sense of what that meant or what it would look like?
当他们说，我们要分成小组进行有争议的案件听证会时，你是否有任何感觉这意味着什么或者它看起来会是什么样子？
None. Nope, none.
完全没有。不，完全没有。
So what did you do? Did somebody tell you, you go into this room with these people?
那么你做了什么？有没有人告诉你，你和这些人一起进那个房间？
[LAUGHS] What did I do?
[笑] 我做了什么？
Yeah.
是的。
I shit a sideways brick is what I did. I mean, I had no idea. It's just a very confusing scene the first time you're in because I just didn't understand the decorum. I didn't understand how this proceeded.
我吓得要死，这就是我做的。我的意思是，我完全不知道。这是你第一次参加时非常混乱的场面，因为我不理解礼仪。我不理解这是如何进行的。
I mean, I'm sitting in there. And when the guy who came in who looked like a judge and talked like a judge, but what does this look like? Is this real court? Am I the jury? And if I am the jury, do I behave the same way a jury behaves?
我的意思是，我坐在那里。当那个看起来像法官、说话像法官的人进来时，这看起来像什么？这是真正的法庭吗？我是陪审团吗？如果是陪审团，我的行为举止是否和陪审团一样？
Dr. Loyd told me he did have a brief orientation that morning, but no special training, no real prep for this. Basically, he was just thrown into it. So at Dr. LaPaglia's hearing, he kind of winged it, went with his gut. And he identified with Dr. LaPaglia.
劳埃德医生告诉我，他那天早上确实参加过简短的迎新，但没有特殊培训，没有任何实质性的准备。基本上，他只是被扔进去了。所以在拉帕利亚医生的听证会上，他有点临场发挥，随心所欲。他认同拉帕利亚医生。
Dr. Loyd is an addiction doctor. He spent two years as Tennessee's opioid czar. And also, like LaPaglia, he's in recovery from a pill addiction.
劳埃德医生是一名成瘾医生。他曾担任田纳西州的阿片类药物沙皇两年。而且，和拉帕利亚一样，他也在从药瘾中恢复。
And so as they're presenting this, here's this figure that I don't know the background on that looks pretty sympathetic. He's done the things you need to do. I'm a second chance guy.
所以当他们展示这一切时，这里有一个我不了解背景的人物，看起来很令人同情。他做了你需要做的事情。我是个相信第二次机会的人。
He related to Dr. LaPaglia. He had also made bad decisions while in the throes of a drug addiction. Although to be clear, LaPaglia testified he was sober at the time he was writing the fraudulent prescriptions and had been for years.
他与拉帕利亚医生有共鸣。他在毒瘾发作时也做过糟糕的决定。尽管要明确的是，拉帕利亚作证说他在开具欺诈性处方时是清醒的，并且已经清醒多年了。
I think I equated, hey, this guy did these things. While I didn't write scripts, I stole medication from people, which is bad. And I got better. And I think he can get better.
我想我等同起来了，嘿，这个人做了这些事情。虽然我没开处方，但我从人们那里偷过药物，这很糟糕。我好转了。我想他也能好转。
For Loyd, LaPaglia said all the right things. He said he was drawn to treating people with addictions to benzos because that's what he was addicted to. He said he took issue with the way addiction clinics were treating patients with benzo addictions, that they weren't giving them enough pills to taper effectively.
对劳埃德来说，拉帕利亚说了所有正确的话。他说他被吸引去治疗那些对苯二氮卓类药物成瘾的人，因为他自己就是对那个成瘾的。他说他不同意成瘾诊所治疗苯二氮卓类药物成瘾患者的方式，因为他们给的药丸不足以有效地戒断。
They were given possibly two weeks' worth of benzodiazepine and then taken off.
他们可能只给了两周的苯二氮卓类药物剂量，然后就停掉了。
OK, and what would happen after they were taken off? Were they just clean of benzos?
好的，那停掉之后会发生什么？他们是否清除了苯二氮卓类药物？
It's never going to happen.
那是不可能发生的。
So what would happen?
那么会发生什么？
They're going to relapse 100% of the time.
他们100%会复发。
I could see Dr. Loyd nodding along. When Dr. LaPaglia was talking about the problem of dual addiction between opiates and benzos and the problem of relapse on benzos, I was like, I could see Dr. Loyd nodding along.
我能看到劳埃德医生点头。当拉帕利亚医生谈论阿片类药物和苯二氮卓类药物的双重成瘾问题以及苯二氮卓类药物的复发问题时，我当时就在想，我能看到劳埃德医生点头。
What I heard from him is, I've got these patients who are addicted to benzos. These doctors don't know what they're doing, trying to get them off. And you actually can't get them off that quick. They'll just relapse. He's exactly right. That's exactly right.
我从他那里听到的是，我有一些苯二氮卓类药物成瘾的病人。这些医生不知道自己在做什么，试图让他们停药。你实际上不可能那么快让他们停药。他们只会复发。他说得完全正确。完全正确。
After the attorneys were done questioning Dr. LaPaglia, the board members got a turn.
在律师完成对拉帕利亚医生的质询后，委员会成员轮流提问。
But first of all, thanks, Dr. LaPaglia, for coming today and being honest.
但首先，谢谢你，拉帕利亚医生，今天能来并保持诚实。
Here's Dr. Loyd.
这是劳埃德医生。
So your training in addiction is on the job from the folks at Express and then the eight-hour X-waiver class?
所以你在成瘾方面的培训是在Express的同事那里得到的，然后还有八小时的X-豁免课程？
Correct.
正确。
OK.
好的。
But most of his questions, he's testing LaPaglia, trying to see if he really understands addiction medicine.
但他大多数问题都在测试拉帕利亚，试图看他是否真的了解成瘾医学。
Can you tell me how you establish a diagnosis of substance use disorder, severe?
你能告诉我你是如何建立重度物质使用障碍诊断的吗？
Through discussing, taking a drug history, going over medical history with the patient.
通过讨论、记录药物史、与患者一起回顾医疗史。
And so did you ever follow the criteria of the DSM-V for substance use disorder and classifications of mild, moderate, and severe?
那么你有没有遵循DSM-V关于物质使用障碍的标准以及轻度、中度、重度的分类？
No, we didn't put that in the chart.
不，我们没把它放进图表里。
OK, and when you're training-- by way, I 100% agree with you about the prevalence of benzos. That's spot on. But when you're treating benzodiazepine dependence, what is your goal?
好的，当你培训时——顺便说一句，我100%同意你关于苯二氮卓类药物流行程度的看法。那很准确。但当治疗苯二氮卓类药物依赖时，你的目标是什么？
Complete abstinence is the goal.
完全戒断是目标。
OK, and so how do you get there?
好的，那你怎么达到那个目标？
Extremely slowly.
极其缓慢地。
This goes on for several minutes. Dr. Loyd only asks two questions about the L&B scheme itself. When they finally get to deliberations, Dr. Loyd speaks first.
这持续了几分钟。劳埃德医生只问了两个关于L&B计划本身的问题。当他们终于开始审议时，劳埃德医生先发言。
I'm the newest member of this committee or this board. And I was told that my charge was to protect the health, safety, and welfare of the citizens of the state of Tennessee. And do I believe that taking Dr. LaPaglia's license does that? I actually don't. I don't believe that it does that.
我是这个委员会或这个理事会的新成员。我被告知我的职责是保护田纳西州公民的健康、安全和福祉。我相信吊销拉帕利亚医生的执照能做到这一点吗？我其实不这么认为。我不相信能做到。
From what I saw today, and hopefully, I'm a decent judge of somebody's heart, I saw somebody that cares about taking good care of a population that struggles to find help. That's what I saw.
从我今天所看到的，希望我是一个能判断人心的人，我看到的是一个关心照顾那些难以找到帮助的人群的人。那就是我看到的。
One aspect of these medical board hearings that's very different from a criminal trial-- because of transparency laws in Tennessee, the panel members have to deliberate in the open in front of Dr. LaPaglia.
这些医疗委员会听证会与刑事审判非常不同的一个方面是——因为田纳西州的透明度法律，小组委员会成员必须在拉帕利亚医生面前公开审议。
Rebecca says this is another reason the discipline can be so light. It's really awkward for them, raises some potential issues. Like at one point, while the panel members are considering requiring Dr. LaPaglia to get board certified in addiction medicine, LaPaglia interrupts them, steers them away from it.
丽贝卡说这是纪律处分如此之轻的另一个原因。这对他们来说非常尴尬，引起了一些潜在的问题。比如在某个时候，当小组委员会成员考虑要求拉帕利亚医生获得成瘾医学的委员会认证时，拉帕利亚打断了他们，把他们从这个方向引开。
Do we want to require him to do that, and if he doesn't complete--
我们想要求他这样做吗，如果他不完成——
I respectfully ask no because I may change my mind, or something else may happen. And if I don't fulfill that requirement, I'm never going to get off probation.
我恭敬地请求不要，因为我可能会改变主意，或者发生别的事情。如果我没有完成那个要求，我就永远别想结束缓刑期。
The administrative judge has to break in and tell them to quit talking to each other. In the end, here's what the panel decides. They're going to restore Dr. LaPaglia's medical license, which had been summarily suspended in January, when the board first found out about the L&B scheme.
行政法法官不得不插嘴告诉他们停止互相交谈。最终，小组委员会决定了如下内容。他们将恢复拉帕利亚医生的医疗执照，该执照在1月份委员会首次发现L&B计划时被简要暂停。
As punishment, they give him five years probation, make him report to the Tennessee Medical Foundation. It's a physician's substance abuse group. And they tell him to take a few professional courses. They don't prohibit him from prescribing controlled substances. He still doesn't have a DEA number, so technically, he can't anyway. But he could petition the DEA to get it back. They don't restrict that either.
作为惩罚，他们给他五年缓刑，让他向田纳西医学基金会汇报。那是一个医生药物滥用小组。他们告诉他去参加一些专业课程。他们没有禁止他开具受控物质。他仍然没有DEA号码，所以从技术上讲，无论如何他都开不了。但他可以向DEA申请恢复。他们也没有限制这一点。
It's actually a lighter discipline than what he would have gotten from the plea agreement, the one the board threw out for being too easy on him.
这实际上比他从认罪协议中获得的纪律处分还要轻，也就是委员会因太轻而否决的那个协议。
So yeah, it was a slap on the wrist. Dr. LaPaglia was all smiles afterwards. So I had chatted with him at the breaks. And he was sort of saying, I'm just hoping to get my license back. And I got this federal thing I got to deal with.
所以是的，这只是轻描淡写。拉帕利亚医生事后笑逐颜开。所以我在休息时和他聊过。他当时大概是说，我只是希望能拿回执照。我还有这个联邦问题要处理。
And so, for some reason, they decided to insert this language at the end that says, to give him a path back to full licensure. And when they read that out loud, Dr. LaPaglia winked at me.
所以出于某种原因，他们决定在最后插入这段话说，给他一条通往完全执照的道路。当他们大声读出来时，拉帕利亚医生对我眨了眨眼。
Whoa.
哇。
Which really surprised me. It just really surprised me. I was like, did that just happen?
这真的让我很惊讶。我当时就像，那是真的发生了吗？
How did you interpret his wink?
你怎么解读他的眨眼？
I think that he was sort of saying, see, I'm getting what I wanted-- I guess. I think it went even better than he expected. And I think that might be why he winked at me.
我想他大概是说，看，我得到了我想要的——我想是这样。我想这比他预期的还要好。我想这就是他对我眨眼的原因。
So I went up to him afterwards to talk to him. And by this time, I had chatted with him a couple times. And he said something like, I'm just glad to have my license off of suspension so I can make some money. It was a real kind of 180 from the patient care testimony that he had just provided.
所以事后我走过去和他谈话。到那时，我已经和他聊过几次了。他说了一些类似，我很高兴我的执照取消暂停，这样我可以赚点钱。这和他刚才提供的病人护理证词完全是180度大转弯。
I reached out to Dr. LaPaglia about this, but he didn't get back to me.
我就此联系了拉帕利亚医生，但他没有回复我。
So here you've got a doctor who lost his DEA number when he was caught with illegal prescription drugs and marijuana at his house in what looked very much like a drug trafficking operation, whose medical license was put on probation, who then went out and broke the law again by using another doctor's DEA number to prescribe controlled substances.
所以在这里，你有一个医生，当他在家里被发现持有非法处方药和大麻时失去了DEA号码，这看起来非常像毒品交易，他的医疗执照被处于缓刑期，然后他又再次触犯法律，使用另一位医生的DEA号码开具受控物质。
And now here he is, back on probation with the medical board, still with a medical license, which means he can still work as a doctor. In the years that she's been going to medical board meetings, Rebecca has watched a bunch of doctors with egregious histories keep practicing medicine, doctors who have committed health care fraud, doctors who prescribed controlled substances for people who aren't their patients, doctors who have sex with patients.
而现在他在这里，再次处于医疗委员会的缓刑期，仍然持有医疗执照，这意味着他仍然可以作为医生工作。在丽贝卡参加医疗委员会会议的几年里，她看着许多有恶劣历史的医生继续行医，那些犯了医保欺诈的医生，那些为非患者的人开具受控物质的医生，那些与病人发生关系的医生。
One doctor prescribed large doses of opioids and other drugs, even though the patients had no medical reason for taking them. Prosecutors asked the board to permanently revoke his license, but he was only put on probation.
一位医生开了大剂量的阿片类药物和其他药物，尽管病人根本没有服用它们的医学理由。检察官要求委员会永久吊销他的执照，但他只被处于缓刑期。
As far as I can tell, Tennessee is fairly typical. A statistical study ranked medical boards on a scale of how harsh to light their discipline was. Tennessee was smack in the middle. Of course, I'm talking about the worst cases the medical board sees.
据我所知，田纳西州相当典型。一项统计研究将医疗委员会的纪律从严厉到轻微进行了排名。田纳西州处于正中间。当然，我指的是医疗委员会看到的那些最糟糕的案例。
And the board does revoke some doctor's licenses. Since 2017, they've taken 13 licenses away, and 11 doctors have voluntarily surrendered them. That's a significant punishment. As one board member explained to me, a medical license is technically a property right. And it's a big deal to take someone's property from them.
委员会确实吊销了一些医生的执照。自2017年以来，他们收回了13个执照，11名医生自愿交出了执照。那是重大的惩罚。正如一位委员会成员向我解释的那样，医疗执照在技术上是一种财产权。拿走某人的财产是一件大事。
But something does seem to be happening, where medical boards, which are set up to protect the public, to protect the majority of us who never think to ask whether our doctors are safe and operating in our best interests, sometimes the medical boards are letting dangerous doctors continue to practice medicine.
但似乎确实发生了什么事，本应保护公众的医疗委员会，为了保护我们这些从不想去问医生是否安全、是否符合我们最大利益的大多数人，有时医疗委员会却让危险的医生继续行医。
On the one hand, I feel like on some level, I understand this problem because I've spent so long studying it. I've seen all the angles. I've seen how the personalities play out and the incentives and the emotions and everything. But there's also a way in which I just don't get it. I don't understand why they won't just take the guy's license.
一方面，我觉得某种程度上我理解这个问题，因为我花了这么长时间研究它。我看到了所有的角度。我看到了个性是如何展现出来的，激励、情感等等。但还有一种方式是我只是不明白。我不明白为什么他们就是不吊销那家伙的执照。
What's the part of you that understands it?
理解它的那部分你是怎么想的？
[SIGHS] I think that there's a identification that's not as specific as, oh, that could be me. That's still in play of just being a doctor. This is our calling. We went to similar sets of trainings. We started out walking down the same path.
[叹气] 我认为有一种不那么具体的认同，比如，哦，那可能是我。那仍然是一种作为医生的认同。这是我们的使命。我们经历了类似的培训。我们最初走的是同一条路。
So I think there is some identification at a kind of very high professional level, like a circling the wagons. Like, we're doctors. And then I think there's also-- and this is probably especially bad for doctors, but they're just kind of softies. They just believe that everybody can be healed and can be made better and are sick and deserving of compassion.
所以我认为在高专业水平上有一种认同，就像围成一圈。就像，我们是医生。然后我认为还有——这对医生来说可能特别糟糕，但他们只是有点软心肠。他们只是相信每个人都可以被治愈，可以变得更好，而且是生病的，值得同情。
I mean, that's what's really ironic and sad to me, is that it's, in some ways, this whole problem is created by that better part of human nature, the part that's full of mercy.
我的意思是，这对我来说才是真正讽刺和可悲的地方，在某些方面，整个问题是由人性的那一更好部分创造的，那部分充满了怜悯。
Rebecca's solution to this whole thing?
丽贝卡的解决方案是什么？
Well, I think we need to abolish licensing boards, to be perfectly honest.
嗯，说实话，我认为我们需要废除许可委员会。
Instead of having doctors sit in judgment of other doctors and instead of having them do this as a favor to society every few months, Rebecca says have full-time employees whose job it is to regulate the industry, who are trained to notice when they're being affected by the emotional sway of a defendant, and to put their feelings aside as much as possible, like a judge would. Dr. Loyd agrees with Rebecca, in part. He admits he did relate to LaPaglia, and it influenced how he thought about discipline.
与其让医生评判其他医生，与其让他们每隔几个月做一次顺水人情，丽贝卡说，要有全职雇员，他们的工作就是监管行业，他们受过训练，能注意到自己是否受到被告情感影响，并尽可能地把自己的感受放在一边，就像法官那样。劳埃德医生部分同意丽贝卡的观点。他承认他确实对拉帕利亚产生了共鸣，这影响了他对纪律处分的看法。
If I saw the facts of the case written down on a piece of paper, right? Just boom, right down-- start at the top, go to the bottom. And I get to read that piece of paper without anybody from either side, right? And I just read that, I'd revoke his license.
如果我把案件的事实写在纸上，对吧？就那样——从头开始，一直写到底。我读那张纸时没有来自任何一方的人，对吧？我只是读了它，我会吊销他的执照。
Just based on the, he used another doctor's DEA license number to prescribe patients.
仅仅基于他用了另一位医生的DEA执照号码来给病人开药。
Just based on flat facts-- drug charges, used another doctor's DEA license, drug dealing, right? Just the plain facts, no defense attorney, no prosecutor. I just saw that written down on a piece of paper, no LaPaglia in the room-- I'd revoke his license.
仅基于客观事实——毒品指控，使用了另一位医生的DEA执照，毒品交易，对吧？仅仅是平铺直叙的事实，没有辩护律师，没有检察官。我只是把它写在纸上，没有拉帕利亚在房间里——我会吊销他的执照。
Hm, that's so interesting.
嗯，那真有趣。
And this is something-- well, it's something I've gained an appreciation for. And I'm really trying to work on this as a board member. It is very difficult to sit there with another human being in front of you and-- what I want to say-- drop the hammer.
这是我获得的一种认知。作为委员会成员，我真的在努力解决这个问题。坐在那里，面前有一个人，然后——我想说的是——重锤落下，真的很困难。
It's a human being, right? It's much easier on a sheet of paper, right? Because when I'm sitting there, I see a guy that's presenting this way. He doesn't look emaciated. He looks healthy. He's dressed professionally. He's got a child that he has emotion around, like me as a dad. Do I want to give him a chance to get that back? Yeah, I do.
这是一个人，对吧？在纸上容易得多，对吧？因为当我就坐在那里时，我看到一个表现成这样的人。他看起来并不憔悴。他看起来很健康。他穿得很专业。他有一个他有情感的孩子，就像我作为一个父亲一样。我想给他一个机会让他拿回那个吗？是的，我想。
But it's not fair to say that's the whole reason the case went askew, that doctors looked too kindly on a fellow doctor sitting before them. Because when considering what to do with LaPaglia's medical license and whether he should be a practicing doctor, the board members never got a full airing of his past misdeeds. As soon as the hearing was over, Dr. LaPaglia did something that made Dr. Loyd suspicious.
但说那是案件出错的全部原因并不公平，医生对坐在他们面前的同行太宽容了。因为在考虑如何处理拉帕利亚的医疗执照以及他是否应该成为一名行医的医生时，委员会成员从来没有全面地了解他过去的恶行。听证会一结束，拉帕利亚医生就做了一件让劳埃德医生怀疑的事情。
I stood up and was headed out, and he approached me. And I can't remember his exact words, but it was very placating, almost like, hey, I appreciate what you've done in your own life. I would like to have that, right? That kind of thing. And I knew it was bullshit.
我站起身准备离开，他走向了我。我不记得他的具体词汇了，但非常安抚人心，就像，嘿，我赞赏你在自己生活中所做的一切。我希望能有那个，对吧？那种事情。而且我知道那是狗屁。
He felt like he was being manipulated. Something about LaPaglia's affect felt fake.
他觉得他被操纵了。拉帕利亚的某种影响感觉很假。
I knew I had made a mistake. My little man inside of me that I use as my barometer of people was like, oh, man, Steve, this guy is a shyster. He kissed my ass, and I couldn't fucking stand-- I'm sorry to cuss, Dana. I'm--
我知道我犯了错误。我内心深处用来衡量人的晴雨表说，噢，伙计，史蒂夫，这家伙是个骗子。他拍我马屁，我他妈的受不了——抱歉，达纳。我——
No, it's fine.
不，没关系。
I couldn't stand it. I couldn't stand it. It wore me. So I went outside and googled him. I said goodbye to everybody. I walked out to my car. I grabbed my phone-- or my truck. I sat there, and I googled his name. And the first article that popped up in the way I searched it was the article about his domestic violence.
我受不了。我受不了。它折磨着我。所以我走到外面用谷歌搜了他。我和大家道别。我走到我的车前。我抓起我的手机——或者我的卡车。我坐在那里，用谷歌搜了他的名字。我搜到的第一篇跳出来的文章就是关于他家庭暴力的文章。
Andrew Coffman didn't talk about the restraining order against LaPaglia at the trial. It's not a criminal charge. And besides, he said, while it clearly demonstrates bad conduct, it isn't bad conduct related to the practice of medicine.
考夫曼在审判时没有谈到针对拉帕利亚的限制令。那不是刑事指控。而且此外，他说，虽然这清楚地证明了糟糕的行为，但这不是与行医相关的糟糕行为。
But that's not all he left out. In 2010, while working as an ER doctor, LaPaglia did something that a federal appeals court said, quote, "shocks the conscience." The police brought a young man named Felix Booker to the ER. They suspected Booker was hiding drugs on his body-- up his butt, to be blunt.
但这不是他漏掉的全部。2010年，在作为急诊医生工作时，拉帕利亚做了一件事，联邦上诉法院称其“震撼了良知”。警察把一个叫菲利克斯·布克的年轻人带到了急诊室。他们怀疑布克把毒品藏在身体里——直白地说，藏在屁股里。
Dr. LaPaglia asked Booker to consent to a rectal exam. Booker was naked, except for a blanket, and in handcuffs and leg shackles. He said no. LaPaglia says Booker consented to the exam, but nobody else who was in the room heard this. And there's no medical record of it.
拉帕利亚医生要求布克同意进行直肠检查。布克全身赤裸，只有一条毯子，还戴着手铐和脚镣。他说不。拉帕利亚说布克同意了检查，但房间里的其他人没有人听到这个。而且没有关于此的医疗记录。
LaPaglia tried to examine him. Booker clenched his muscles, so LaPaglia had him sedated. Booker was still able to clench his muscles down, so LaPaglia had him medically paralyzed, intubated him, and did the rectal exam. He found a rock of crack. LaPaglia testified at Booker's trial that he'd done rectal exams on two other people the police had brought in to him.
拉帕利亚试图检查他。布克咬紧肌肉，所以拉帕利亚让他服用了镇静剂。布克仍然能够咬紧肌肉，所以拉帕利亚让他医疗性麻痹，插管并进行了直肠检查。他发现了一块快克毒品。拉帕利亚在布克的审判中作证说，他曾对警察带给他的另外两个人做过直肠检查。
A year after that, there was a fourth guy, Wesley Gulley. Gulley alleged he got the same treatment. LaPaglia asked him to consent to a rectal exam. He said no. LaPaglia threatened to sedate him and paralyze him, so he relented. LaPaglia did the rectal exam and found nothing. The police charged Gulley with resisting arrest. The hospital charged him for the rectal exam.
那之后的一年，有第四个人，卫斯理·格利。格利声称他遭到了同样的待遇。拉帕利亚要求他同意直肠检查。他说不。拉帕利亚威胁要让他服用镇静剂并让他瘫痪，所以他屈服了。拉帕利亚做了直肠检查，什么也没发现。警察指控格利拒捕。医院对他进行了直肠检查收费。
But apparently, nothing ever happened to Dr. LaPaglia. He wasn't criminally charged for the warrantless, no-consent rectal searches. He didn't even lose his job at the hospital. The searches were reported to the Department of Health, but Dr. LaPaglia was not disciplined for them.
但显然，拉帕利亚医生从未受到任何惩罚。他没有因为非法、未经同意的直肠搜索而被刑事指控。他甚至没有失去在医院的工作。搜索事件被报告给了卫生部，但拉帕利亚医生没有因此受到纪律处分。
And in a cruel regulatory irony, because he was not disciplined, there's no public record of why the board did not discipline him. Dr. Loyd actually found out about the rectal searches from Rebecca. They had coffee a few weeks after Dr. LaPaglia's hearing.
在一个残酷的监管讽刺中，因为他没有受到纪律处分，没有关于为什么委员会没有对他进行纪律处分的公开记录。劳埃德医生实际上是从丽贝卡那里得知直肠检查的事。在拉帕利亚医生听证会几周后，他们喝了咖啡。
I mean, that's bringing up emotions right now I can't even-- that's somebody who's taken advantage of their position of power. That's not forgivable. Maybe God could forgive him, but I can't.
我的意思是，那现在激起了我甚至无法——那是有人利用了他们的权力地位。这是不可原谅的。也许上帝能宽恕他，但我不能。
I can tell you this. If he paralyzed my son in the ER, I would have fucking killed him. I mean, I would've. I would've went after him. I don't care. They just said, you know, well, you're going to-- you know, you want to pay consequences for this, Steve? Fine. He paralyzed him. He paralyzed his muscles against his consent. The guy did not give consent for that.
我可以告诉你这个。如果他在急诊室让我儿子瘫痪，我他妈会杀了他。我的意思是，我会的。我会追杀他。我不在乎。他们只是说，你知道，好吧，你要——你知道，你想为这个付出代价吗，史蒂夫？好。他让他瘫痪了。他未经同意让他肌肉瘫痪了。那个人根本没有给那个同意。
Yeah, he had to be intubated. I mean, he couldn't even breathe on his own.
是的，他必须插管。我的意思是，他甚至无法自己呼吸。
No, no, you can't. I mean, you paralyze all muscles, and your diaphragm is a muscle. So you're not going to able to breathe. Yeah, and that's somebody who will do anything. That's just incomprehensible to me.
不，不，你不能。我的意思是，你让所有肌肉瘫痪，你的横膈膜就是肌肉。所以你不可能能够呼吸。是的，那是会做任何事的人。这对我来说简直是不可理解的。
Dr. Loyd and the other board members on LaPaglia's panel, all they knew was that LaPaglia had been on probation with the board once before for charges related to his personal drug use, that he'd been treated for a pill addiction and had stayed sober all these years, and that he and Dr. Brooks got caught selling prescriptions using Dr. Brooks's DEA number, which is a way tidier story than the one I just told you.
劳埃德医生和拉帕利亚小组的其他委员会成员，他们所知道的只是拉帕利亚因为与个人吸毒有关的指控曾一次受到委员会的缓刑，他因为药瘾接受了治疗，多年来一直保持清醒，他和布鲁克斯医生因为使用布鲁克斯的DEA号码销售处方而被抓，这是一个比我刚才告诉你的故事整洁得多的故事。
But Coffman didn't talk about the rectal searches at Dr. LaPaglia's hearing because of the rules of evidence, he told me. It wouldn't have been admissible. Same for the details about the 2014 drug charges, which, by the way, after LaPaglia pled no contest, he was put into something called judicial diversion. It's a kind of probation. And eventually, the case was dismissed.
但考夫曼在拉帕利亚医生的听证会上没有谈论直肠检查，因为证据规则，他告诉我。那本来是不可采纳的。关于2014年毒品指控的细节也是如此，顺便说一句，在拉帕利亚没有抗辩后，他被置于一种叫司法分流的系统中。那是一种缓刑。最终，案件被撤销了。
But more importantly, Coffman said this wasn't a hearing about everything LaPaglia had ever done-- just this one crime, the fraudulent prescriptions. Dr. Loyd didn't learn about the rest of it until it was too late.
但更重要的是，考夫曼说这不是关于拉帕利亚曾经做过的所有事情的听证会——只是这一个罪行，欺诈性处方。劳埃德医生直到为时已晚才了解到其余的事情。
When I'm looking at him up there, I mean, it looked like he was doing what he was supposed to be doing. He's trying his best. Sure, that's what I felt. And I think I am a good judge of that, given all the facts. But I didn't have all the facts.
当我在那里看着他时，我的意思是，看起来他正在做他应该做的事情。他在尽力。肯定，那就是我的感觉。而且我认为我是个很好的判断者，考虑到所有的事实。但我没有所有的事实。
How many strikes do I believe that somebody gets, Dana? As many as they need. In the real world, there's no such thing as the third strike to me. But this is not the real world. You have a professional medical license, and you can harm others. There is a strike limit there.
我认为某人有几次机会，达纳？只要他们需要多少次就有多少次。在现实世界中，对我来说没有第三次机会这回事。但这不是现实世界。你拥有专业医疗执照，你可以伤害他人。那里有一个罢工限制。
Dr. Loyd says he asks a lot more questions now during these cases. So how to keep this from happening? How to make sure the board gets a full picture of a doctor's career and past misdeeds before they decide how to discipline them?
劳埃德医生说他现在在这些案件中问的问题多了很多。那么如何防止这种情况发生？如何确保委员会在决定如何惩罚医生之前得到医生职业生涯和过去恶行的全面画面？
Rebecca points to a simple and practical solution-- separate the disciplinary hearing into two parts. Have one hearing where the board hears evidence and decides if a doctor is guilty of the charges, and another hearing where the doctor is disciplined. And at that point, they can learn other information about a defendant's past, both good and bad.
丽贝卡提出了一个简单而实用的解决方案——将纪律听证会分为两部分。举行一次听证会，委员会听取证据并决定医生是否有罪，另一次听证会医生受到惩罚。在那一点上，他们可以了解被告过去的、无论好的还是坏的其他信息。
That's how criminal courts work. Once the jury has determined a person's guilt, the judge is the one who does the sentencing and gets to hear more about the defendant. This solution, Rebecca points out, has the benefit of being readily available to the board. It's already legal under Tennessee law.
刑事法庭就是那样运作的。一旦陪审团确定了一个人的罪行，法官就是那个进行量刑的人，并有机会听到更多关于被告的事情。丽贝卡指出，这个解决方案的好处是委员会可以立即使用。根据田纳西州法律，这已经是合法的了。
Last September, the medical board members and staff had an offsite retreat. Rebecca was there. She recorded it for her notes for her book on licensing boards. And one of the things they discussed was Dr. LaPaglia's case, what had gone wrong. Dr. Loyd was still upset about it.
去年9月，医疗委员会成员和工作人员举行了外部研讨会。丽贝卡在现场。她把录音记在了她关于许可委员会的书的笔记里。他们讨论的事情之一是拉帕利亚医生的案件，哪里出了问题。劳埃德医生对此仍然感到不安。
Dr. LaPaglia is a practicing doctor in Tennessee right now. He does house calls for $50 cash. And Loyd explained what he sees as the real problem with that kind of outcome, with this halfway discipline they gave LaPaglia. They've made it so he can't get a job at a hospital or a medical clinic, but he can still see patients.
拉帕利亚医生现在是田纳西州的一名执业医生。他以50美元现金进行家庭出诊。劳埃德解释了他所认为的那种结果的真正问题，这种他们给拉帕利亚的半吊子纪律处分。他们搞得他无法在医院或诊所找到工作，但他仍然可以看病人。
Dr. Loyd said, quote, "He can only work in a cash-based practice, and so the most vulnerable Tennesseans are the ones at risk. And that's not awesome because the very population that I work personally with on a daily basis. I just put somebody back out there, and I'm struggling with that."
劳埃德医生说，引用：“他只能在现金为主的诊所工作，所以最脆弱的田纳西人是面临风险的人。这并不好，因为那正是每天我个人工作的人群。我刚刚把某人重新放出去，我正在为此挣扎。”
Dana Chivvis is one of the producers of our program. Rebecca Allensworth wrote about medical boards and Dr. LaPaglia's case for the New York Review of Books.
达纳·奇维斯是我们节目的制片人之一。丽贝卡·艾伦斯沃思为《纽约书评》撰写了关于医疗委员会和拉帕利亚案件的文章。
[MUSIC - "YOU DON'T NEED A LICENSE FOR THAT" BY GEORGE FORMBY]
[音乐 - 乔治·福姆比的《你不需要执照》]
Our program was produced today by Sean Cole. The people who put our program together today includes Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Aviva DeKornfeld, Hilary Elkins, Noor Gill, Damien Grave, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由肖恩·科尔制作。今天将节目拼凑在一起的人包括比姆·阿德武米、艾尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、达纳·奇维斯、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、希拉里·埃尔金斯、努尔·吉尔、达米安·格雷夫、米基·米克、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sara Abdurrahman, senior editor, David Kestenbaum, our executive editor, Emanuele Berry. Special thanks to David Wendy Helgeson, Reid Magney, Scott McDonnell, and Jakob Elberg. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Plus, there's videos. There's lists of favorite programs. There's tons of other stuff on there, too. Again, that website, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的总编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼，高级编辑大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆，我们的执行编辑伊曼纽尔·贝里。特别感谢大卫·温迪·赫尔格森、里德·马格尼、斯科特·麦克唐奈和雅各布·埃尔伯格。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们700多集的档案。此外，还有视频。有喜爱节目的列表。上面还有很多其他东西。再次重申，那个网站，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He and his wife are finally taking their first vacation since quarantine. I think they're going to have a good time. He read me their packing list.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心发送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他和他的妻子终于在隔离以来第一次休假。我想他们会玩得很开心。他给我读了他们的打包清单。
45 quart-sized Mason jars which contained marijuana, 127 glass pipes used to smoke marijuana, Glock 19 9 millimeter.
45个装有大麻的夸脱大小梅森罐，127个用于吸食大麻的玻璃烟斗，格洛克19 9毫米手枪。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "YOU DON'T NEED A LICENSE FOR THAT" BY GEORGE FORMBY]
[音乐 - 乔治·福姆比的《你不需要执照》]